في ابرز التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا افادت السلطات الاوكرانيه
بتعرض العاصمه كليب ومقاطعات اخرى لموجه
جديده من الهجوم الروسي بعشرات مسيرات
ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شاهد وقالت القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها اسقطت احدى
واربعين مسيره اثنتان 22 منها فقط في كياف
واضافت موجه الهجمات الجديده استهدفت
مقاطعه
البلاد
العسكريه التي يرسلها الحلفاء باتت تساهم
في حمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيه بشكل اكثر
فعاليه
في بنيه التحتيه المدنيه واصابه مدنيه في
منطقه في العاصمه فضلا عن انقطاع عن جزئيا
في التيار الكهربائي
من روسيه ان عددا من الجنود الروس قتلوا
واصيبوا في قصه اوكرانيه تجمع لقوات
التعبئه في ارضك بصواريخ خاي مارس وفي
روسيا افاد حاكم مقاطعه برنسيه المحاضره
لاوكرانيا لكزاندر بوكماز بان مسيره
اوكرانيه هاجمت منطقه كليمفو جنوبه غربيه
المقاطعه
فان الهجوم الحق اضرار بمرفق للطاقه وقطع
لي وقطع الكهرباء عن بلده كليبوفو دون
وقوع اصابات بشريه
كلها الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت
صاروخا روسيا بعيده المدى وثلاثه طائرات
مسيره من طراز شاهد ايرانيه الصنع وكانت
تحاول استهداف منشات حيويه في المدينه
وكذلك الشوق انا احدى الطائرات المسيره
استهدفت تجمعا سكنيا في احد ضواحي مدينه
دنبرو وبث ناشطون على مواقع التواصل صورا
يسمع فيها دوي انفجار قالوا انه بلحظه
سقوط احدى المسيارات في المدينه
ان القوات الروسيه قصفت اراضي المقاطعه
التي تقع جنوبيه اوكرانيا نحو 40 مره خلال
الساعه الماضيه
واصابه اخرين بجروح والحاق ابرار ماديه
باحد مستشفيات المدينه
كيف مراسلنا ثاني راس ماضي تامر اخر
تطورات بخصوص ما خلفته وماخلفه هذا القصف
على العاصمه اكيد ولد ما قالته كذلك
القوات الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكرانيه عن
اعتراضه لمسيارات ايضا
نعم مريم احب الفعل نحن نتحدث وفقا ونقلا
عن القوات الاوكرانيه والاداره العسكريه
والمدنيه هنا في كياب عن موج جديد من
الهجمات تستهدف كياف وعديد المقاطعه
الجنوبيه هذه المره بالمسيرات الايرانيه
من نوع شاهد كما قالت السلطات وكما قالت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه القوات الجويه
تحدثت عن اسقاط واحد 41 همم مسيره همم في
عموم البلاد 22 طائره مسيره اسقطت بالفعل
هنا في قلب العاصمه كياب السلطات المحليه
عمده المقاطعه الاداره العسكريه تحدثت عن
ان همم القصف استهدف بشكل اساسي البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه طبعا لم تشر السلطات
العسكريه هنا الى عدد الطائرات التي تمكنت
بالفعل من استهداف البنيه التحتيه لكن
الحديث عن 22 طائره تم اسقاطها من قبل
الدفاعات الارضيه ومن قبل القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه القوات الجويه تحدثت بان
المعدات التي باتت تحصل عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه على اختلاف فئاتها من
الشركاء الغربيين باتت تؤثر في سير
المعركه وتحديدا في سير اسقاط المسيارات
وفي الحقيقه كانت هنالك تصريحات مهمه
للمخابرات الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات
الماضيه التي كانت بان نقص ما سمته بنقص
الصواريخ من نوع كاليبر الروسيه بالاضافه
الى همم نقص حاد كما قالت في صواريخ
اسكندر باتي يدفع القوات الروسيه الى
اللجوء الى المسيرات وتحديدا المسيرات
التي حصلت عليها موسكو من طهران خلال
الفتره الماضيه وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه
ال- ال- القصف كما اشرنا استهدف عددا اخر
من المقاطعه تتحدث عن المقاطعات
ميكولايبسون
وكل هذه
تعات الواقعه جنوب البلاد والسلطات
والادارات العسكريه هنالك تحدثت ايضا عن
اسقاط عدد منها وكاله بانها كانت تحاول
استهداف النيه التحتيه استهداف البنيه
التحتيه تحديدا هنا في العاصمه ادى الى
انقطاع جزء في التيار الكهربائي وفقا
للسرطان التي تحدثت ايضا عن استهداف
لاحد المناط او احدى المناطق السكنيه ما
ادى الى اصابه مواطن وتحدثت ايضا عن مقتل
همم مواطن او ان مواطن اخر فارق الحياه
نتيجه القصف الذي تعرضت له العاصمه اول من
امس تعلمين جيدا مريم بان همم الكيف تتعرض
منذ ايام لهجوم متواصل اما بالمسيرات واما
همم بالصواريخ ولذلك اغلب الوقت العاصمه
تضل تحت همم يعني حاله التاهب الجوي
والانذار المستمر عمده المدينه دعاء
السكان اليوم مجددا الى اخذ الحيطه والى
الالتزام يعني الانذارات الجويه عندما
تنطلق بان تغلق محل التجاريه وايضا يتوقف
الناس عن اعمالهم وايولدوا بالملاجه وفي
الحقيقه بعيدا عن هذا القصف الذي جرى فجر
اليوم تتواصل تتواصل المعارك ويتجدد القصف
والقصف المتبادل في الحقيقه بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول الجبهات
تحديدا في المناطق الجنوبيه والشرقيه خلال
الساعات الماضيه يتحدث هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه عن اصابه اكثر من 170 جنديه
الروسيه في منطقه زباروجه تحديدا في ريف
زبروجه الجنوب الحديث عن اليوتيوب ماك في
حين قال عمده الاوكراني بان هذا العدد من
الجرح بات في همم اعداد القتلى وصفه
وتحدثت السلطات ايضا عن اصابه عدد من
الاعداد والذخيره والمستودعات الاسلحه
الخاصه بالقوات الروسيه في الريف الزمان
الجنوبي على وجه التحديد ونهايه عثمان
القصف يتواصل على خير خلال دقائق الاخيره
تحدثت الاداره تذكريه هناك عن ان اكثر من
70 هجوما روسيا بالمدفعيه باراجونات
الصواريخ وبقذائف الهاون تواصل على القرى
والبلدات الواقعه على خط طول خطوط التماسك